m
[Musique]
on
plus fort
ok ça c'est le genre d'ambiance que
j'aime beaucoup quand la salle est dans
l'euphorie je me sens comme sur un tout
petit nuage et je me suis je me sens
vraiment dans mon b vous savez quand
j'étais tout petit mon rêve c'était
d'être une super star ah oui j'aime m me
voir comme le jean debuf du monde sur
scène et il ya des bouts
aux premières heures de ma carrière dans
les médias en 2004 je présentais
plusieurs émissions sur la première
chaîne de télévision privée au bénin lc
de télévision et pour ceux qui s'en
souviennent l'une de mes émissions que
je présentais avec beaucoup beaucoup de
joie ces termes codés star et j'avais ma
phrase fétiche beaucoup d'histoires oui
mais le vôtre aussi
je mettais dans la peau de super star
le délire le délire je m'éclatais de ouf
jusqu'au jour où
un gros déséquilibre
tout a basculé
je vais vous conter l'histoire d'une
femme et à l'instant où je long terme je
ne sais pas si elle se termine bien et
c'est mon histoire nous avons semble
remonter le temps jusqu'en
2017 cette année là comme toutes les
autres on s'est présenté les meilleurs
voeux du monde
le tap rouleau était peint joliment
mais vite très vite du gris s'est testé
du premier trimestre de 2010 est j'ai
perdu deux de mes voisines toutes les
deux sont partis du cancer du sein
toutes les deux étaient des épouses des
mères elle était intelligente avec de
briey cas de brion de carrière devant
elle
mais trop vite trop tôt elles sont
parties
jour après jour semaine après semaine je
maniais du noir dépensé ténébreuse
commencé à prendre de l'espace dans mon
esprit
je commençais à être convaincu que
peut-être moi aussi j'avais le cancer du
sein
je mets pour moi ces deux deuils
pouvait-il m'affecter à ce point
en 2017
j'avais un master en géosciences de
l'environnement et développement durable
au cours de ma formation j'ai été exposé
à une panoplie d'études de recherche de
publications scientifiques qui pesait le
lien entre les problèmes
environnementaux et les problèmes de
santé le lien entre les problèmes
environnementaux et le nombre croissant
de cancers au bénin au nombre de ces
études et recherches scientifiques il y
en a particulièrement une dont les
résultats étaient en grève inscrit sur
mon écran script au mental c'était les
travaux du professeur pas où le
professeur la zone une sacrée dame
intelligente forte et très courageuse
le professeur pas ou dans ses travaux a
révélé que le fleuve ogooué mais qui
prend sa source au nord du bénin et qui
arrose tout le pays jusqu'au sud est
pour lui y est pas des résidus de
pesticides
tous les cours d'eau bene d'une manière
ou d'une autre interagissent avec l'oeuf
le vomi
le professeur bazou ajoute
que les poissons et crustacés pêchés
dans les eaux sont polluées par des
résidus de pesticides
alors pour vous que j'ai une question à
quand remonte la dernière fois que vous
avez consommé de la soupe de poisson
frais pêché dans les eaux
moi je viens de la belle cité balnéaire
située au sud ouest du bénin la
magnifique ville de grand popo avec ses
jolies plages et fumoir le dénommé
préféré c'est le da cau l on le cuisine
avec de la soupe de poisson frais et
j'en ai mangé littéralement toute ma vie
durant
alors quand je pensais aux travaux du
professeur pas où est sa fiche et les
images de mes voisines parti trop tôt il
ya ben eo2 d'appoint
qui rythmaient le groupe de mots cancers
cancers cancer du sein
jour après jour j'étais victime de ses
pensées folle et ténébreuse
parce que nous avons fait ce pas on
démontre que quand vous mangez la soupe
de poisson frais pêchés dans l'eau zoo
vous consommez sans qu'on s'en de
résidus de pesticides
[Musique]
quand vous fumez les poissons vous
réduisez de 40% les résidus de
pesticides mais quand vous les faites
frire vous réduisez de 60% les résidus
de pesticides alors le meilleur mode de
cuisson demeure la friture de poissons
bien entendu vous pouvez mettre du
papier absorbant pour retirer le gras
avant consommation
pour moi c'était très difficile mais on
battait quand ça moi même devant mon
miroir alors que je scrutais ma poitrine
et que juste à côté mon coeur battait au
rythme endiablé de ses pensées folle je
me suis dit inès
tu dois faire quelque chose parce qu'en
j'avais un master en géosciences de
l'environnement et développement durable
mais j'avais aussi ayant démarré ma
carrière en 2004 13 années d'expérience
dans les médias
c'est à ce moment-là que j'ai dit bye
bye à mes rêves de super star et que
j'ai enfilé le costume d'entrepreneurs
c'est à ce moment là qu'est née berthe r
b nay mon entreprise la première au
bénin est entièrement dédié aux
questions de communication
environnementale
avec mon équipe nous sommes assigné la
tâche d'aller aux quatre coins du monde
ouvrir les conférences sommet et forum
sur les questions environnementales afin
de rendre l'information environnementale
acee cible en gage père à terre mais
aussi sur le terrain nous avons décidé
de faire des reportages des productions
audiovisuelles pour maintenir les
équilibres en suisse entre ce qui se
passe au niveau global est ce qui se
passe localement
avec dessous travail que nous faisions
au cours d'un an et demi je me suis dit
il faut quand même que tu saches
[Musique]
situe à ce concert ou pas il faut que tu
saches si ses pensées folle qui relevait
de la virtualité et qui
malencontreusement
se présentait dans la réalité de ton
corps était fondée ou pas
je prends mon courage à deux mains je
vais voir au gynécologue
il me prescrit une mammographie
le jour même je fais cette mammographie
et au bout de quelques heures j'avais
entre les mains une grosse enveloppe
kaki qui contenait les résultats
plusieurs questions taraudaient mon
esprit mais la principale était si
seulement si ce match avait été exposée
plus tôt au résultat scientifique le
professeur pas où tu aurais pu prendre
de bonnes décisions par rapport à ton
alimentation
et tu ne serais pas là maintenant
victimes de toutes ces pensées
qui te tiennent dans l'étau
je vais voir le gynécologue
il était serein voulait pas laisser les
médecins il prend l enveloppe ils
ouvrent ils me regardent et en langage
terre à terre il me fait
mal d'amour vaucelles sont plus que
c'est il n'y a pas le moindre soupçon de
cancer du sein
[Applaudissements]
de nouveau je pouvais vivre goodbye
envolées tous ses doutes ses pensées
folk ouvert en fait s'évanouir
s'évaporer et j'étais à nouveau moi mais
plus que jamais j'étais déterminé
j'étais décidé à rendre l'information
environnementale acee cible en langage
terre à terre il est écrit instruit
l'enfant dès son jeune âge quand à la
fois qu'il doit suivre et quand il sera
vieux ils ne sont détournera pas au delà
de ce que nous faisions avec mon équipe
nous avons décidé de toucher d'autres
cibles nous avons alors initié le
programme tous écolos tous écolos n'est
qu'une réplique de ce dont j'ai
bénéficié moi même étant plus jeune
quand j'étais au collège à travers le
programme globe global learning and
observation to benefit devait remettre
ce programme permettez à mes parents et
moi d'avoir dans notre collège une mini
station météo on pouvait mesurer la
température minimale maximale la
pluviométrie identifier les nuages dans
le ciel mais surtout nous ne jetons rien
nulle autre part que dans des poubelles
avec tous écolos nous investissions les
écoles écoliers enseignants et elle a
aussi instruit nous rejetions des vidéos
qui sensibilisés à la protection de
l'environnement il pouvait mieux
comprendre le phénomène de changement
climatique s'engager pour les questions
d'eau d'hygiène et d'assainissement
ce programme marché bien et plaisait
énormément aux écoliers et enseignants
jusqu'au jour où la cog hill 19 familles
une pause à cette noble cause
elles nous est tombée dessus tel un coup
de massue et de nos habitudes tu es tu
nous as fait cocu tous avons été
victimes d'un violent brutal on l'aurait
voulu banal mais la robic 19 est fatale
les vieilles ces barrières sont devenus
une précaution vital car ce virus
gendarmes et notre monde à désarmer
excusez moi du peu mais tout est parti
en couille quand il a mis le feu et nous
a foutu la trouille
désormais le monde se perd il peine à
retrouver
repères l'économie sans terre la
planétaire a dû se taire et mon équipe
et moi avons dieu nous tourner vers le
père
au viol ou mauvais destin face à ce
virus liberté il m'a point dégâts pour
la richesse et à la provôté point de
tendresse 2000 souci mon esprit sambath
à l'idée que l'environnement
s'embarrasse le déchets qui s'entassent
camp de mon cash les je me débarrasse et
j'ai quelques autres embarras les eaux
usées çà et là après le lavage des mets
par ci par là autant de désagréments
environnementaux qui ont amené mon
équipe et moi à nous réinventer
les conférences internationales
désormais se tiennent majoritairement en
ligne nous avons dû nous adapter pour
tous écolos nous avons saisi la géniale
idée et opportunités des technologies de
réalité virtuelle pour les enfants c'est
plus attractif et ne battait plus grands
nous allons partout où le besoin se fait
sentir pour rendre l'information
environnementale plus accessible et
maintenant à vous j'ai une question
êtes vous prêt à vous engager à la
protection de notre planète êtes vous
prêt à être vous-même éco citoyen mais
surtout elle vous prêt comme on le dit
dans mon métier qui a le pouvoir qui à
l'information a le pouvoir êtes vous
prêt à vous saisir de ce pouvoir pour
votre santé mais aussi celle de la
planète
si oui
devenez aussi des observateurs contactez
nous envoyer vos informations nous les
rendrons à ses cibles en langage terre à
terre pour toucher plus de couches
encore avec mon équipe nous avons décidé
dans un contexte de covile 19 d'aller
plus loin
nous avons initié des émissions qui ne
se font pas uniquement en français mais
plutôt en font un yoruba mais langues
nationales du bénin nous avons initié
des émissions de divertissement
des jeux plusieurs personnes parlent de
l'environnement et garder l'eau et tout
le monde est content
êtes vous prêts c'est dire l'information
environnementale et en faire un pouvoir
entre mm
je viens de vous conter les soins d'une
femme qui a connu un gros déséquilibre
mais surtout une femme qui a su fait
naître de ces peurs une fleur sans pour
autant laisser mourir la super star en m
et maintenant je dis mon côté
qu'aussitôt et oui mais le vôtre aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]